welcome back to new rock stars i'm erik
voss and marvel's a falcon the winter
soldier delivers the thrills and
memeable moments fans love
but most impressive about this series is
that the closer you look at many of
these scenes
we've discovered that a huge portion of
this narrative was actually a miraculous
rescue operation in the show the group
of militants known as the flag smashers
led by carly morgenthau
i believe was originally intended to
follow a very different storyline
one disrupted by the covet 19 pandemic
not just the show's shooting schedule
but
a scripted mystery subplot about a
global virus
that disney and marvel were forced to
reconceive rewrite reshoot and re-edit
into the existing story structure now i
began to uncover some of the clues in my
episode 3 breakdown found a few more in
episode 4
and i've since gone back to all the
other episodes to try to figure out what
this storyline was going to be
exactly what was changed and why so
after being introduced to the flag
smashers in episode 1
episode 2 shows them shipping stolen
crates that bucky identifies
stealing medicine vaccines carly later
gets a text from the power broker
reading you took what was mine i'm going
to find you and kill you and the power
brokers men force them to flee with few
of their stolen goods now we
never hear about those vaccines again
now the things the power broker is mad
about carly stealing are actually the 20
super soldier serum vials which carly
keeps in a little medical pouch
while the vaccines on the truck were in
these huge freezer crates in episode 3
the flag smashers bring supplies to a
latvian grc
resettlement camp despite this group
supposedly being on the run from the grc
carly plays soccer with the kids when a
voice calls out to her
golly
there's not much time you should be with
her now
now we don't see who is talking to her
here actress aaron kellyman just kind of
vaguely
looks over and then goes inside as if
the voiceover line was added in adr
that's when actors come into a recording
booth
after the shoot in order to get cleaner
audio to dub over the scene to be clear
adr happens on every film in tv
production especially ones with as many
field shoots as this series
like whenever characters movies are
outside and windy or
loud or super active conditions they
almost always come back in later to dub
over the audio hell we even reshoot the
video and audio at different times for
new rockstars videos like notice later
in the video when i shout out our
sponsor my hair is going to change a
little bit it's why god invented editors
really the weirder element of this scene
was the character of dania madani played
by veronica falcone a
talented actor with a large body of work
including hbo's perry mason
and the upcoming jungle cruise movie
with the rock she is a
get and yet her role was reduced to a
non-speaking woman dying of a mysterious
illness now that illness is later
identified as tuberculosis by dr nagel
in another line that was clearly dubbed
in later via adr
but a couple of days ago she called and
asked if i could help someone
named donya madani poor woman has
tuberculosis
typical of overpopulation and
displacement camps like that
i mean even dr nagel's connection to the
power broker
also sounded like it was added in
post-production we got a name
wilfred nagel
nagel works for the power broker we need
your help sharon now later in this
episode was a scene with
unusually rushed exposition explaining
how carly and dovich ended up in magipur
after the blip forced them out on the
street that they went there hoping to
find
something and then somehow stole the
power brokers top secret super soldier
serum that
our team of high-powered well-conceived
operators spent pretty much all of
episode 3
struggling to access episode 4 features
similar suspect editing like the flag
smashers reaction to carly's bombing in
lithuania
the grc formally began drafting
legislation known as the patch act
which would seek to restore traditional
border regulations and fast track
the return to normalcy yeah we cut
directly from an overhead shot of carly
standing away from all of them to
suddenly sitting amongst them with this
80 yard newscaster voice over
an insert of a smartphone with stock
news b-roll no news outlet identifier
and then a later scene with the flag
smashers uses an
excessive amount of reaction shot
coverage and gonna definitely feel like
dub dialogue it's the power broker
play revolutionary on borrowed time
little girl
i want the serum back or i will find you
and i will end you
we separate them and then we kill
captain america
but back to sharon carter look closely
at her phone call with sam
hey sam you gotta play this out
if carly disappears we're not going to
find that serum until it's too late
i know the power broker went ape [ __ ]
when he heard about nagel he wants the
serum back
you killed the golden goose now later in
this episode sharon has a bloody lip and
scars on her knuckles presumably from
her scuffle in the shipyards in episode
three
but here in the phone call her lip looks
fine and everything she says about the
serum and the power broker and nagel
comes when she is off screen even her
line about the golden goose doesn't
really match emily van camp's mouth
movement
you killed the golden goose magikor is
about to get real nasty
really sharon carter has been one of the
more cryptically written characters in
the series
after being labeled criminal for helping
cap in civil war she has since
established herself as a
multi-millionaire dealer of stolen art
and madrapore
despite avengers end game confirming she
was blipped for five years
and now she really only would have been
active for like six months
she seems to have some unidentified
connection to the power broker that as
of episode 4 we have not been told much
about
so is all of this evidence of a re-shot
subplot
involving the flag smashers dhoniya
madani the power broker nagel and sharon
carter
oh what's that oh sorry one second i
just kind of get a little snack in the
middle of this
i've been trying to eat better which
means trying to avoid extra sugar and
the bad stuff that is why i am not
[ __ ] on magic spoon cereal it's got
no junk in it but
it tastes really good it's almost too
good for how healthy it is so in this
stuff there's zero grams of sugar
14 grams of protein and only four nat
grams of carbs in each serving also only
140 calories
it's gluten free gmo free and all the
other bad stuff free i really love the
peanut butter flavor
it's like your favorite peanut butter
cereal but like it's a lot better for
you oh and big news magic spoon just
brought back the blueberry flavor it's
kind of like when the mythical mick rib
comes back for a limited time but
good for you click the link below to get
blueberry or any of these flavors today
use my code new rockstars for five
dollars off before these flavors sell
out or you can choose to build your own
box from the best selling flavors of
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
cinnamon and blueberry magic spoon is so
confident in their product it's backed
with a 100 happiness guarantee so if you
don't like it for any reason they'll
refund you no questions asked so click
that link below
the code new rockstars for five dollars
off or go to magicspoon.com
new rockstars to save five dollars on
your order today before they are gone oh
and for all you canadian fans magic
spoon is now shipping to canada
yeah so the falcon in the winter soldier
was supposed to be the first marvel
series on disney plus
scheduled for fall 2020. principal
production went from november 2019 to
march 2020 but at that point covet 19
shut everything down but around this
time there was a
rumor that in addition to production
needing to be rescheduled that scripts
for this show needed to be rewritten due
to a supply that was too similar to the
real world events of the pandemic now
this was never confirmed all we know
about the original plot of the show
comes from that marvel disney plus promo
in february 2020 which showed the aerial
battle with sam and batrock john
walker's football game pr event lucky
and sam arriving at zemo's prison
and sam and bucky with the shield at the
wilson family home and bucky and zemo at
the location of the sakobian monument
that promo had nothing about the flag
smashers nothing about sharon carter or
match report or the serum reshoots moved
to prague in october 2020 prague was the
filming location for all the latvian
scenes meaning all this flag smasher
stuff that we've seen in episode 3 and
episode 4
could have been shot after these changes
were made and by this time marvel
had released a trailer for wanda vision
slid earlier in the schedule perhaps
because as the series mostly shot on
sound stages and studio backlots the
production was not nearly as extensive
as it was for the falcon the winter
soldier which was delayed to after one
division so knowing all this we're
really left with the questions
one how did dhoni madani originally die
and why did this series reduce her role
two what were those vaccines all about
and three why does the exposition in
scenes featuring or about the flag
smashers the power broker or the serum
all feel like it was edited
in after the fact well based on the
evidence i think the likeliest
explanation is that this series did
originally feature a subplot about a
virus maybe one brought on by the sudden
doubling of the global population
flooding cities and towns with billions
of people with immune systems five years
weaker or maybe a bioweapon unleashed
upon this population by terrorists
emboldened by the avengers absence
so this militant group i believe was
originally stealing vaccines because
their matriarch dhonia madani
a bigger role for veronica falcone
became afflicted with this disease
and unfortunately they could not get
back in time with vaccines and then that
led to her death now one could argue
a storyline about a pandemic and
devastating loss due to lack of public
health resources would totally be worth
exploring unless that subplot
originally had some twists that would
look pretty bad for disney and marvel
for
example if this fictional virus were to
be revealed to be a bioweapon released
by the power broker of
madrapore a city in southeast asia
not only could that contribute to
harmful misconceptions about covet 19's
origin and early spread it could also
risk disney's attempts to expand its
business to asian markets
as you can see all kinds of potential
problematic there so the solution
delay the release remove the virus
subplot reduce stonya madani's role
diagnose her cause of death as
tuberculosis and really just
reframe this conflict using other
elements from the series like the legacy
of the super soldier serum using new
footage
and adr dialogue to construct the
narrative we have now i mean we may
never know exactly how extensive these
reshoots had to be
like whether even things like the grc
the group being called the flag smashers
this group being juiced up as super
soldiers in particular
were always intended or added later to
make these episodes without a virus
subplot maintain
some narrative logic look however much
of this is accurate i have to credit the
creative team behind the falcon the
winner soldier
malcolm spellman kerry skoglyn the
producers writers editors the cast we're
pulling together a series with all the
great moments that falcon the winner
soldier has given us
film and tv production often is a
chaotic scramble with unforeseen
challenges
and for them to come out of all of it
with a hit like this is a massive
achievement what do you think the
original storyline of this show was
gonna be i wanna hear your thoughts down
below in the comments
oh by the way this is our anarchy
assembled shirt it is available at
newrockstarsmerch.com and if you've been
following our weekly fitness series
called fitness origins
all the daily workouts that tommy and i
have been doing are going to be uploaded
to the epic hero fitness youtube channel
so that you can join us in this
journey if you like and you can check
out other bts footage that we will be
posting there lots of bloopers lots of
fun stuff so again subscribe to the epic
hero fitness youtube channel you can
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos follow new rockstar
subscribe to new rockstars here on
youtube for breakdowns of everything
marvel thank you for watching bye
[Music]
you